dépenses de campagne dire que lundi dans
ce cas un candidat à une élection a le
droit de dépenser avec son compte de
campagne et comme toute question
d'argent en france en politique les sous
c'est hyper sensible est gelée du coup
super encadré pour pas gâcher interdite
la valse des dépenses sauf si vous êtes
candidat dans une commune de moins de
9000 habitants lassés sans embarras vous
n'avez aucun plafond en contrepartie
vous ne seraient pas remboursés même si
vous faites des reines jambes je vais
conclure en revanche si vous êtes
candidat dans une commune de plus de
9000 habitants la chorégraphie se
complique et les répétitions commencent
un an avant la générale pour les
municipales 2014 toutes dépenses
engagées depuis le 1er mars 2013 est
considéré comme une dépense de campagne
premier mouvement toutes dépenses de
campagne ne peut se faire qu'à partir
d'un compte ouvert au nom d'un
mandataire c'est lui le maître de ballet
lui qu'à le code de la carte bleue
impression de tracts et affiches
location de salles pour les mythiques
oui
costumes coiffures tutu restaurants dont
tu es pour une élection municipale le
montant des dépenses est plafonné en
fonction du nombre de spectateurs dans
la salle le barème est aussi sophistiqué
qu'un tango argentin mais pour le
connaître de vingt mille habitants le
plafond est de 29 mille 89 euros 50 1
mais à l'autre c'est précis comme un
numéro de claquettes
quand un candidat suite tout sépare il
est remboursé après contrôle de ses
comptes par la commission nationale des
comptes de campagne et des financements
politiques
c'est quand même un peu rock'n'roll tout
ça mais le clou du duel n'est peut-être
pas plus